yeah you remember that lifeless soulless
husk of a Pinocchio film the Disney Live
Action released earlier this year
this is not that before we talk about it
I do want to thank the sponsor of this
video this video is brought to you by
nordvpn nordvpn's the VPN service that
aims to help make your navigating this
digital Minefield of the internet a
little safer and a little more secure
because I don't trust humans and that
includes humans on the same public Wi-Fi
as me which is widely ignored VPN
nordvpn allows you to change your
digital location with one click allowing
you to stream movies shows and play
games that might not be available in
your region and for you good folks
taking this internet thing more
seriously which should be all of us
nordvpn has threat protection blocks
malware written websites helps protect
you and your information from trackers
and spies it is your DPS your tank your
entire MMO raiding party protecting you
from the CD underbelly of the internet
and it's all backed by nord's 30-day
money-back guarantee and I love me that
kind of guarantee so click the link
below go to nordvpn.com Johns and users
can get a huge discount with purchase of
a two-year plan plus four additional
months for free all right now I do want
to apologize as this year's kind of away
from me in general so the chaos of life
itself the chaos of December both
collaborated to give me that feeling of
there was something I needed to do and
whoa Guillermo del Toro's Pinocchio came
out like a week and a half ago anyhow
thanks for your patience thanks for
watching here we go
[Music]
the story of Pinocchio brought To Us by
directors Guillermo del Toro and Mark
Gustafson it's a stop-motion animated
film that pays respect to the darker
origin stories of Pinocchio darker than
the Pinocchio story that a lot of us
know you hear that with a lot of those
Disney stories it's like oh yeah Disney
story that's cute the origin story is a
lot darker and right when this film
starts out you know two things are fact
one it's gonna rip your heart out
because it's gibetto hanging out with
his son and in Pinocchio Geppetto
doesn't have a son a son that's not
Pinocchio anyway is this gonna tear my
heart out in the beginning of the film
Up Style not exactly like up it's
actually much darker than up there's
that and second the stop-motion
animation is completely gorgeous it's
fantastic it's beautiful it's art it's
the top Echelon of what I've seen in the
stop-motion Animated World it was
something that actually dawned on me
while I was doing my process before I
film I Pace my kitchen just circle the
island in my kitchen thinking about what
I'm gonna say suppose the process would
go by faster if I took note oats or made
bullet points while I watched the movie
but I don't I find it to be far more
organic word vomiting off the top of my
head acting like I know what I'm talking
about but it's funny that stop-motion
animation is seen as animation but
technically speaking it is real 24
images a second lined up in succession
to trick our brain into seeing motion
which is exactly what live action film
is and the images of live action film or
everybody as real as what's in
stop-motion animation so why is it
considered animation it's animated but
real like Pinocchio that long-winded
explanation is to say that parable of
using stop-motion animation to tell the
story of Pinocchio is both brilliant and
not lost on the audience now what I like
about this film is it's not necessarily
a film for children I mean it is in the
sense that sometimes I've walked out of
children's movies animated movies lately
and I'm like that doesn't have have the
lessons that they old man energy coming
in they don't make them like they used
to it doesn't have the hard lessons
those animated films used to have this
movie actually does have heart lessons
also has some pretty disturbing imagery
in some parts they'll learn some good
lessons they'll also have some
nightmares but as this film does tell us
all magic comes with a price steering
and as I've already said this film is
Magic absolutely just everything in this
film seemed methodically thought out
since we're dealing with Guillermo del
Toro
um it's not seemed it is using
stop-motion animation to tell the story
of Pinocchio using the setting of the
world it's a fascist world of Benito
Mussolini yeah if you remember him the
guy from The Ultimate Showdown of
ultimate Destiny but it's a fascist
world of proverbial strings so again
that's brilliant to tell the story of
Pinocchio strings being a physical thing
or not the only strings that exist in
the world it's a story about Free Will
Choice consequence also Family Life
Death it's a film about mortality really
this whole mythical angle to this film
dealing with life and death and
immortality and this being a new telling
of Pinocchio I like the tension because
I didn't know where it was gonna go
don't mean to keep pairing this to the
Disney Live Action monstrosity that came
out earlier this year but in that film I
just kind of always knew where it went I
knew where it was gonna go even then the
life lessons that the animated Pinocchio
film had that film somehow just kind of
scrubbed it away and said hey Nostalgia
let's do it but this Pinocchio story is
the difference right there it's the
contrast the difference between
Nostalgia bait and telling a story and a
very relatable human and sometimes hard
to watch story I'm kind of talking it up
I'm not saying there's like a super
massacre in the film or anything like
that but it is it's heavy it's one of
those films I can't just pop in at any
time really yeah I'm gonna watch
Guillermo del Toro's Pinocchio let's do
it because it's another day that ends
with why I need to be in the mood to
watch a film like that I mean that in a
good way but still it doesn't change the
fact I I can't just watch this every day
I did run into that moment where I was
like oh where are they going with this
because in the Disney Live Action
Pinocchio there's a scene where
Pinocchio has to lie to grow his nose to
get out of hot water basically get out
of a tough spot this film does a similar
thing and I was like oh it was going so
well why are they doing this this is so
it felt out of character I guess why you
make a Pinocchio lie to get out of
problems but get out of a problem is
it's very loose it's a far more complex
outcome that doesn't negate the lesson
of yeah lies aren't necessarily good so
I must apologize for doubting I didn't
mean to in the end caramel del Toro's
Pinocchio I thought it was incredible
it's a visually Beautiful film with
complex themes interesting characters a
strong family Dynamic that isn't always
warm and fuzzy but it's real I feel like
it transcends its own genre it's a film
of self-discovery to film a family also
a war film at times I was actually
surprised at the fact that yes it has
lessons that would probably be
advantageous for children to learn but
also adults this isn't just a film about
Pinocchio it's very much about Geppetto
too he's learning lessons as Pinocchio's
learning lessons that's very important
because the lessons in life never stop
you never get to a point in life for
it's like yeah I know all I need to know
no more lessons necessary no that's not
a real thing that never happens that's
an illusion there's one day and one day
only you will know that you know all you
need to know and that's the day you die
but on that day you'll be too dead to
know
again that irony is not lost a film
about a little wooden puppet has never
felt more human I know it's Netflix I
hope this doesn't live on Netflix
forever I'm a hard copy Fiend I like me
my hard copies and I say that because
this film is worth watching and worth
buying on Blu-ray alright so Guillermo
del Toros Pinocchio have you seen it
what did do you think about it what's
your favorite stop-motion animated film
that's a good question to ask and I
don't get to ask too often so whatever
it is whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]